you're still you are gonna do one more
film yeah I got one more yeah written
yet or no no I haven't even thought
about it yet really yeah yeah whenever
that idea comes up you know I'll
probably start writing it like I said
I'm Gonna Know hurry on in in that
regards especially right now because I
don't even know what I'd be writing it
for I didn't even you know do movies the
way I have always known them do they
even exist right now I think that
remains to be seen well I think Ten's a
good number okay so it is I think ten
yeah uh uh also I'm at that point where
I think okay it's ready to Bow off the
stage leave them wanting more the don't
make any left-handed movies don't make
any movies for the wrong reason don't
don't muddy up uh my filmography with a
bunch of out of touch Old Man movies
I've had just an amazing career I've had
amazing amount of luck amazing good
fortune and I've been able to work at in
this business at the highest level at
the highest level a director can can
work and I'm gonna leave at that high
level I want to leave where a new
Quentin Tarantino movie uh coming out is
an event